[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm juni möchte
mich heute besonders bedanken dass sie
alle gekommen sind weil dieses diese
woche ist das wetter wirklich schön und
ich glaube wenn ich selber nicht
vorlesen müsste dass ich nicht hier sein
würde
das ist sehr schön dass sie gekommen
sind trotzdem so letzte woche haben wir
das thema ewigkeit des universums
besprochen
diese woche und in der kommenden woche
werden wir zwei weitere themen
besprochen
die damit relativ eng verbunden sind
nächste woche liegt die verbindung auf
der hand nächste woche ist unser thema
die zeit danach mal haben wir eine
vorlesung zum so raum also in den
kommenden wochen könnte man sagen dass
wir die grundprinzipien der physik
abdecken
diese woche bespreche ich freiheit und
determinismus und es liegt natürlich
nicht so offensichtlich auf der hand was
das mit ewigkeit oder mittlerer zu tun
hat aber irgendwie können sie anhand dem
was sich letzte woche gesagt habe können
sie vielleicht erkennen was die
verbindung hier ist denn wir gesehen
haben dass laut den philosophen die welt
oder das universum ewig wahl notwendig
aus god for hervorkommt oder hermann
irrt und das scheint eine gewisse
tendenz in richtung determinismus zu
implizieren also kurzum hat man den
eindruck dass gott der terminiert ist
die welt zu schaffen oder dass er
notwendig die welt schaffen muss und das
war wie wir gesehen haben genau das
problem was razali und andere theologen
mit design als emmi nation wäre gesehen
haben und wir werden diese woche noch
mal ein paar mal zurück zu diesen diesem
problem kombination notwendigkeit des
universums aber hier geht es und
vorwiegend nichts darum zu erkennen ob
das was gott macht notwendig ist sondern
ob das was wir machen wie wir handeln
notwendig sein könnte und damit sind wir
bei den klassischen problem der freiheit
mit determinismus was immer noch mitte
physik in der jetzigen zeit prägt was
ist dieses problem ist also im grunde
genommen ist ganz klar die frage ist
sind wir frei zu handeln und die meisten
philosophen scheinen davon auszugehen
dass wir natürlich frei handeln denn wir
ohne freiheit nicht verantwortlich sind
für das was wir tun zum beispiel nehmen
wir an dass ich von ihnen geld klauen
dann stellte sich heraus dass ich keine
wahl hatte also dass ich nicht frei war
es als sich so gehandelt habe würden sie
mich wahrscheinlich sofort verzeihen zb
also sehr etwas abwegiges beispiel aber
nehmen wir an ich glaube ihm geld weg
und dann finden sie heraus
ich würde von einem bösen
wissenschaftler gesteuert das science
fiction mäßig es gibt natürlich science
fiction filme wo das passiert dann
würden sie den wissenschaftler
beschuldigen und nicht mich genau weil
ich so handeln müsste und anhand dieser
intuition würden viele philosophen und
auch sogar normale menschen
sagen mich dass wir vieles offen nicht
normal sind
aber sie wissen was ich meine viele
würden sagen dass wir freiheits und
deswegen moralische verantwortung
verantwortung nur besitzen wenn wir
zwischen mehrere mögliche handlungen
wählen dürfen
das heißt nicht bei der normalen
menschen sondern bei den philosophen
libertarian is muss also das ist die das
ist die these dass man nur frei zu
handeln ist wenn man zwischen mehr als
eine möglichkeit wenn kann nur also
klassisch werde die mit zwei
möglichkeiten entweder so handeln oder
nicht
also ich bin ich hier gibt es eine
handlung und eine misshandlung und ich
als freier 23 handelnder mensch kann
zwischen diese diesen zwei möglichkeiten
wählen
natürlich ist es oft so dass wir
zwischen mehr als einer handlung wählen
zb ich wähle zwischen also zuerst
vielleicht ein beispiel mit einer nicht
handlung vor 20 minuten war es mir noch
offen einfach im büro so bleiben und
nichts mehr her zu kommen und diese
vorlesung nichts zu geben
also ich hätte einfach sitzen bleiben
können
wäre schade gewesen natürlich zum glück
habe ich mich zusammengerissen bin
hergekommen und handel jetzt da dort das
sich diese vorlesung halte also und man
könnte dieses sitzen bleiben halt
einfach also eine nicht handlung
interpretieren ja oft ist es eher so
dass man zwischen mehreren möglichkeiten
wählen muss die einzelnen verschiedene
handlungen seien zum beispiel ich hätte
hier her kommen können und diese
vorlesung halten oder in den englischen
garten gehen und das wetter genießen
nichts die ständig daran zu erinnern
dass sie das gemacht hätten sollen die
marken hätten wir immer diese web ketten
sind nicht mein lieblings aspekt der
deutschen sprache auf jeden fall also
das wäre eine andere handlung aber
natürlich wenn ich ihm den englischen
garten geht das setzt voraus dass ich
nichts
die vorlesung gehe gebe also eine andere
handlung zu wählen setzt voraus dass ich
nichts diese handlung in schallwellen
okay so das ist liebe bertha realismus
wie gesagt ist es hier sehr wichtig dass
beide möglichkeiten offen sind und
freiheit ist vielleicht die fähigkeit
oder die kraft eine möglichkeit zu
wählen anstatt handeln wo sie sich
ausschließen
kompatibel ist muss ist grob gesagt die
idee nein ich kann auch frei handeln
auch wenn nur eine möglichkeit mehr
offen ist
also nur die handlung die ich hoffe ich
mich entscheide
zum beispiel gehen wir jetzt wieder 25
minuten zurück wir sitzen im büro und es
fällt mir gar nicht ein dass ich meine
eigene vorlesungen schwarzen könnte
natürlich werde ich das halten ich denke
nicht daran dass es andere möglichkeiten
gibt ich mach sozusagen einfach
automatisch oder das geht einfach aus
meinem charakter hervor weil ich so
verantwortungsvoll denn würde gut
erzogen amerikaner tun so was nichts
würde schande an meinem land bringen das
letzte was man jetzt traut ist merck
schande
also schon erlebt und deswegen handle
ich einfach sozusagen als ob das die
einzige möglichkeit wäre ja und wenn
wenn sie mich fragen hätten sie anders
handeln können vielleicht würde ich im
nachhinein sagen ja im prinzip schon
aber gemein mit den bedingungen die
damals vorhanden waren war es irgendwie
doch nicht möglich also nicht nur nicht
klar siebel oder wahrscheinlich aber
nicht einmal möglich dass ich anders
handeln finden sie vielleicht ein
anderes beispiel denken wie zum beispiel
sie sehen ein kennt in der straße in das
kennt wird sofort von einem lastwagen
überrollt sie überlegen nichts
sie greifen einfach einen und sie das
kind weg in sicherheit
und man könnte sagen also selbst wenn
sie dafür gelobt werden würden sie
vielleicht sagen na ja also ich hätte
nicht anders handeln können
natürlich habe ich das gemacht oder mein
lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist ist heiraten
also nicht dass das nicht um das mit dem
gefahr eines ankommenden master sowie
gleich aber wenn sie wie viele von ihnen
sind verheiratet ein drittel also als
sie sich entschlossen haben zu heiraten
haben sie hoffentlich nicht gedacht wir
könnten heiraten ja okay also natürlich
können wir das auch nicht machen aber
wir entscheiden uns dafür
hoffentlich haben sie das gefühl das ist
das einzige was ich will ich will das
unbedingt machen ich würde lieber
sterben als nicht diese frau wisse man
nicht heiraten
das nicht so überzeugt dass ihre frau
hier anwesend vielleicht fragen wir sie
später
sie war und in dem fall also wenn sie
bereits hin zu sagen okay ich war
trotzdem frei so handeln mit den
beispielen kennt oder mit heiraten gibt
es eine handlung wo keine andere
möglichkeit wirklich vorhanden war
wenn sie bereit sind zu sagen dass wir
auch dann eine freie entscheidung haben
also frei wahrscheinlich nicht im sinne
von frei wählen zwischen verschiedenen
möglichkeiten sondern frei im sinne von
nichts bezwungen werden weil niemand
würde sagen also mit niemand würde sagen
ich würde bezwungen das canon zu retten
oder meine frau heiraten obwohl ich
keine anderen möglichkeiten hatte anhand
den bedingungen die vorhanden waren also
meine persönlichkeit die welt wie es
damals war und so weiter dann wenn sie
bereits in zu sagen ich kann so ich kann
eine handlung wählen und frei wählen die
mich dafür entscheiden ohne andere
möglichkeiten zu haben dann sind sie
kompatibel ist
weil sie der meinung sind dass freiheit
mit notwendigkeit
kompatibel ist normalerweise spricht man
hier von der terminus muss habe ich
schon determinismus was ist
determinismus determinismus ist die
these dass alles was in grob werden
später sehen das ist mehr als eine art
von kapitalismus gibt aber grob ist
kompatibles muss die ansicht dass alles
was in der welt vorkommt notwendig
vorkommt also alle ereignisse sind
notwendig hätten nicht anders sein
können also die oder die weit wie es ist
muss so sein wie es ist kann man wie sie
es kann man verschiedene ausdrücken aber
sie verstehen die idee oft will wer das
gesagt das kompatibel ist muss die
ansicht ist dass freiheit mit der
terminus muss campari kompatibel ist
das ist wenn alles notwendig ist kann
ich frei handeln
aber meiner meinung nach ist das nicht
ganz richtig
für mich ist kompatibel ist muss die
ansicht dass es vorkommen kann dass man
frei handelt obwohl man notwendig
gehandelt hat es kann auch sein dass
dass man manchmal also wenn sie sich vor
im allgemeinen ist normalerweise der
fall dass man verschiedene möglichkeiten
offen hat aber trotzdem sage ich selbst
wenn jetzt keine andere möglichkeiten
gibt wenn es nur eine möglichkeit gibt
wenn sie diese möglichkeit wählen
ohne andere möglichkeiten zu haben wenn
wenn sie der ansicht sind sie können
diese einen handlung denen und trotzdem
frei sein
sind sie kompatibel ist und es egal ob
sie auch der meinung sind dass
determinismus im allgemeinen bei ist
verstehen sie was ich meine also anders
von wird wenn es nur einmal in der
ganzen geschichte der welt vorkommt dass
jemand freihandels aber notwendig
handelt dann ist kein zynismus war war
die tcs notwendigkeit ist mit freiheit
kompatibel es egal ob man auch manchmal
frei handelt ohne notwendigkeit aber
natürlich wenn determinismus wahr ist
muss man kompakt kompatibel sein um
überhaupt zu sagen dass freiheit
existiert weil wenn komplette wenn
determinismus war es dann sind alle
ereignisse notwendig und deswegen wenn
es freie entscheidung gibt muss es
manchmal vorkommen dass ereignisse frei
gewählt werden
obwohl sie alle notwendig sind natürlich
würden die terminlisten die
kompetentesten sind nichts behaupten
dass alle ereignisse frei vorkommen
zum beispiel gibt es also einfach so
große ereignisse der physik zb ein stein
fällt vom berg runter und niemand würde
sagen nämlich an dass die der stein sich
frei dafür entschlossen hat der punkt
wäre es gibt manche ereignisse die frei
geschehen mache ich hier nichts wenn ein
libertarian ist sagen würde dass die
ereignisse die freikommen immer von
verschieden aus verschiedenen
möglichkeiten frei gewählt werden würde
ein kompatibles was anderes sagen müssen
zb es gab keinen zwang oder der frei
agierende die feiern agierende person
wollte das machen was sie gemacht hat
das ist also zum beispiel wenn sie mich
fragen warum ich hier bin um diese
vorlesung hat zu halten würde ich sagen
es ist mir eine freude
und der grund wofür ich nicht schwänzen
wollte ist dass ich es gibt buchstäblich
nichts dass ich in diesem moment lieber
machen würde
dass das wohl rein hypothetisch das werk
des beispiels also wenn das aber dass
wenn das wirklich stimmt können wir
sagen ja ich bin hier frei weil ich das
machen wollte
nicht weil ich es nicht mehr sind nicht
frei weil ich andere möglichkeiten hatte
aber sie nicht genommen habe das ist
hintergrund für das was wir in der
flüsse wie der islamischen welt heute
sehen werden also kurzum können wir
sagen dass innerhalb der islamischen
theologie also kalam das ist eine streit
gab zwischen sehr eine sehr klare
liberta realistische lippetal
realistische position die von den worten
sie bieten vertreten würde
und eine andere position die vielleicht
kompatibel ist und das ist die
alphabetische position nicht vergessen
dass die asche retten
das resultat war zum beispiel und auch
die sogenannte philosophen oder die fifa
gelten vielleicht aus kompatibel ist
das ist aber komplizierter als das weil
die asche riten scheinen zu glauben dass
die freiheit gottes so funktioniert der
buddhistisch werden die freiheit der
menschen
der menschliche freiheit funktioniert so
wie sie sein werden
also man könnte hier ein sternchen tun
und sagen
gott ist groß was wir jetzt sehen werden
und nachdem wir diese gegen houston
bestreiten werde was zu determinismus
sagen
und vor allem werden wir ein berühmtes
argument für determinismus als alles
versprechen und die rezeption davon bei
alfa die wahlen in der islamischen welt
okay aber bevor ich jetzt anfange hat
jemand fragen zu der philosophischen
darstellung die ich gerade skizziert
habe ist alles klar
dieses diese frage war eine haupt
streitfrage in der tradition des kellers
und wie gesagt es ist sehr klar dass die
mortalität arian listen sind sie und ihn
zwar aus dem grund dass ich schon gesagt
habe nämlich das moralische
verantwortung voraussetzt dass man frei
handelt und als kompatibel ist könnte
man sagen ihr also du bist frei zu
handeln solange du das gemacht hast was
du machen wolltest aber die warter
salaten fanden das nicht zu erreichen
und haben immer darauf bestanden dass
menschen frei handeln können mit herbert
deutschland dass man von verschiedenen
möglichkeiten sehen kann also wie mein
bild vorher und klassisch wildemann
wieder eine sünde begehen oder nichts
zum beispiel hier werdet vielleicht für
die vorlesung nicht so auch für die
vorlesung nicht so oft hast du davon
werde die sonde es leider ein bisschen
ein bisschen verwirrend also nehmen wir
ein anderes beispiel an geld klauen
also wenn ich jemandem geld steht dann
begehe ich eine sünde und ich kann das
entweder machen oder nichts und die
handlung die woraus diese hunde besteht
ist die mutter suiten natürlich ein
akzidenz die irgendwie geschaffen werden
muss da sind nicht vergessen
galler am physik wir haben die
substanzen die atheistische verstanden
werden
und dann haben wir akzidenzen in diesem
substanzen also die handlung ist hier
natürlich keine substanz also akzidenz
und im allgemeinen werden substanzen so
wohl wie akzidenzen von gott geschaffen
aber hier wollen die mieten sagen nein
der mensch ist hat die macht diese
handlung zu schaffen oder kreieren
weil der mensch sonst nicht moralisch
verantwortlich werden ist noch schlimmer
wenn gott diese dieses akzidenz diese
handlungen schafft ist nicht nur dass
ich nichts dafür verantwortlich sein
gott ist dafür verantwortlich er hatte
stellen geschaffen nichtig und dann
haben wir zwei probleme eigentlich ein
problem ist wenn ich in die hölle wenn
ich in die halle komme kann ich dann zu
recht mich bei cos beklagen
hey warum haben sie habt ihr mich in die
hölle geschickt das also liebe gott du
hast es doch gemacht wie ich
du hast diese handlung geschaffen
nichtig also erstens dass und zweitens
liebe gott hast du in die rolle gekommen
weil du hast das gemacht das natürlich
nichts antrieb war und deswegen haben
die die parasiten behaftet dass menschen
die handlung handlungen schaffen können
und zwar in der haken weise dass sie
schaffen wenn sie nicht geschaffen
schaffen können hätten also genau wie
gott entweder die welt schaffen kann
oder nicht kann ich entweder die eine
handlung schaffen oder nicht
das hat eine vielleicht überraschende
verbindungen zu einem anderen thema was
wir ein paar sei erwähnt haben vor ein
paar wochen nämlich vor der vielleicht
letzte woche nämlich die ewigkeit des
korans sie erinnern sich vielleicht dass
ich damals gesagt habe dass wir gott
oder ist ein wesen haben und dann
verschiedene attribute die ihm gehören
anscheinend also seine macht sein wissen
seine großzügigkeit und die monatsmieten
um die einheit gottes zu schützen
wollten dann verneinen dass diese
attributen hat die bitte von gott
verschieden sind entweder dadurch dass
sie einfach verneint haben dass die
attribute überhaupt treffen sind oder er
normalerweise haben sie gesagt ja gott
hat diese attribute also zum beispiel er
ist weise es mächtig dabei seien im
markt und sein wissen sind mit gott
also diese es gibt keine indikation hier
ist nur eine identität
ok und dann habe ich gesagt ein beispiel
davon war das wort gottes mehr mit koran
und hier hat man ein hat man die wahl
entweder sagt man ja seine ein ganz
normaler als gebot gottes und es mit
gott identisch oder man sagt der koran
würde geschaffen ist nicht ewig und die
monatsmieten haben gesagt dass der koran
geschaffen würde
genau wie die welt also sind nicht so
wie die macht gottes ist mehr wie ich
und dann könnte man sich fragen warum
haben sie nicht für die andere
möglichkeit entschieden warum haben sie
nicht gesagt der koran ist das wort
gottes und es mit gott identisch genau
wie seine macht sein wissen und so
weiter komplizierte frage aber ein grund
dafür ist dass manche personen in dem
koran erwähnt werden und genannt werden
aus sünder die in die halle kommen
werden zb der onkel des profits wird im
und er war ein starker gegner der das
für einen islams und heißt ab und im
sims oder 111 des korans wird es
ausdrücklich gesagt er ist herr sünder
er kommt in die hölle und die mutter
suiten hatten dann angst also wenn das
irgendwie hier eingebunden ist
oder damit eingeschlossen ist dass eine
bestimmte person in die hölle kommen
muss und sündigen muss böse sein muss
dann war es schon ewig der fall dass er
so handeln würde und dann hätte er keine
freiheit weil er nicht anders
natürlich hat er nicht die macht das
wort gottes zu ändern
wann das ewige wort gottes und das ist
mit ein grund warum die matas eliten
behauptet haben dass der koran
geschaffen würde das ein bisschen um die
erkenntnis interessanten eigentlich okay
kann die martha siegen ging so weit dass
sie sogar gesagt haben
selbst wenn ich dazu gezwungen werde
dadurch dass meine motivationen und
meine ansichten mich zu dieser handlung
führen bin ich nicht frei also wenn es
zum beispiel wirklich stimmt dass anhand
meiner erziehung und persönlichkeit und
alles was ich über die welt glaube wenn
wenn das alles zusammen mich bezwingt
oder wenn es garantiert dass ich heute
hier auftrete und vorlese dann bin ich
nicht frei das zu tun dass ein bisschen
überraschend aber wenn sie überlegen
können sie sehen dass es nur das sind
genau die verneinung von kampa tourismus
dass die komplette müssten zum beispiel
die story die erste christen würden
sagen solange eine handlung wirklich aus
meiner persönlichkeit oder meiner an
meiner mein wunsch meine ansichten
sondern dass aus mir kommt und nicht aus
einer anderen ursache ist zum beispiel
der böse wissenschaftler der mich
steuert dann bin ich frei dann hab ich
dann wie sich die story gehalten gesagt
es liegt bei mir soll so handeln und die
mieten befürchteten dass sie sagen wenn
die bedingungen einer handlung die
bedingung die die handlungen garantieren
also alles was sozusagen die die volle
situation der welt in dem moment wo ich
handle wenn das wenn diese diese
situation wirklich garantiert oder
notwendig macht dass ich zum beispiel
zur vorlesung komme
dann bin ich nicht frei gib mir nur frei
wenn ich immer noch die fähigkeit habe
nicht zu handeln
klassisch lippe tourismus also jede
position ist sehr klar und damit wollten
sie auch ein wahrscheinlich hatten sie
einfach eine sehr starke intuition dass
das der fall sein muss und vielleicht
eine wahrscheinlich eine intuition die
viele von ihnen teilen also selbst wenn
ich diese beispiele vom kennt und so
weiter sind sie wahrscheinlich also
viele von diensten wahrscheinlich der
ansicht dass wenn ich wirklich keine
andere offene möglich möglichkeiten habe
dass ich nicht frei handeln kann oder
vielleicht sollten wir abstimmen wer
würde sagen dass ich nur frei zu haben
denn wenn ich andere möglichkeiten habe
so nichts zu tun
ungefähr genauso viele
ich denke wir müssen eine
wissenschaftliche studie einführen
panarin war das eine sehr starke
intuition
aber das ist irgendwie nicht der nicht
der gewichts die rehwild tragen die idee
der nationalistischen lehre sondern was
sie wirklich bewegt hat war dass sie die
gerechtigkeit gottes schützen wollten
ihr habt glaube ich ganz am anfang der
ganzen vorlesung serie gesagt dass die
mordtaten sich die anhänger der einheit
und gerechtigkeit achtet auch tadel
so haben sie sich genannt und dieses
problem
ich meine natürlich gibt es keine andere
gott taucht die einheit gottes heißt
mindestens dass es keine anderen götter
gibt aber die die waren auch der meinung
dass die einheit gottes voraussetzt dass
zb keine ewige hat sie gute existieren
die von gott getrennt oder verschieden
sind also die wahren anhänger der
einheit gottes aber genauso wichtig die
wahren anhänger der gerechtigkeit gottes
und ein grundprinzip der gerechtigkeits
sagten sie war niemand kann jemanden
gerechte strafen wenn der bestrafte
nicht freie hand hat vielleicht könnte
man auch sogar sagen dass es nicht
gerecht ist jemanden zu belohnen
denn nicht frei handelt zb nehmen wir an
ich hätte das kind ohne eine wahl zu
haben und gott würde mich dann in den
himmel schicken
vielleicht würden die mieten sagen also
wenn es gereicht erst mich so zu
belohnen hätte dann müsste ich frei sind
das keine freiheiten aber natürlich ist
das also eher könnte gross er könnte
großzügig sein das ist kein problem
also ist selbst wenn er das zu sagen
mir nicht schuld nicht in die herrliche
schicken wäre es so sagen moralisch okay
wenn er das macht aber was nicht okay
ist ist wenn er mich bestraft ohne mir
die chance zu geben anders zu handeln
also die marge auswirken würden sagen
wenn ich geld stelle und nicht vermeiden
konnte geld zu stellen und wenn gott
nicht dafür bestraft dann ist er unfair
und des und deswegen um die
gerechtigkeit der person zu schützen
haben sie dann gesagt dass es mehr als
eine möglichkeit gibt wenn es aber mehr
als eine möglichkeit gibt brauchen wir
eine erklärung warum diese möglichkeit
gewählt würde und nicht diese und das
kann nicht gott sein weil wenn gott die
handlung schafft ist er wieder derjenige
der gehandelt hat und er hat mich
gezwungen soll so handeln also
beziehungsweise ihr habt gar nicht
behandelt gehandelt er hat gehandelt hat
das stellen kreiert nichtig und deswegen
ist er wieder verantwortlich also wieder
nicht gerecht also es gibt sozusagen
hier zwei schritte die die rechte gottes
zu schützen
er ist damit also damit er nicht
erschaffen klar warum damit er mich
direkt bestrafen kann muss ich erstens
eine wahl haben und zweitens muss ich
als handelte behandelte person sich
ruhig muss derjenige sein der die
handlung wählt gegenüber der nicht
handlung okay das ist die politische
position und klingt gut oder
mein logisch schlüssig vielleicht sogar
richtig mein mann kann auch gott
entfernen mit physisch unmöglich aber
konzeption möglich sind wir atheisten
sind können wir sagen okay es geht ja
nicht um gott es geht um die
naturgesetze oder sowas
und wenn die naturgesetze nicht
bezwingen so handeln dann werde ich nie
geschlafen also zb wenn die naturgesetze
wollen anfangs situationen der welt als
ich geboren wurde oder meine erziehung
und so weiter also wenn all diese hinter
liegende ursachen mich dazu zwingen oder
garantieren dass sich so handeln können
wir sagen dann wäre es um werk zunächst
solide strafen
es gibt übrigens an marke der
terminlisten das ist nicht eine nicht
eine sehr nicht eine sehr beliebte
position aber es gibt die terminlisten
die libertarian listen sind also das
heißt die sagen unfall so handeln muss
man mehr als eine möglichkeit haben
aber es kommt nie vor weil determinismus
war ist es notwendig deswegen handelt
niemand frei der termin ist der 1
da von den ich nur erwähnt weil sein
name so super ist ist ein berg terrible
ja vielleicht werde ich mein kind mein
nächstes kind des problems also her und
andere terminals sagen es gibt keine
freiheit weil determinismus war ist pech
gehabt
wir haben kein wir können nicht bei
handel und ein argument für diese these
ist dass wir also wenn wir das wirklich
akzeptieren würden würden wir viel
milder um mit zum beispiel kriminelle
umgehen weil wir sehen würden dass sie
keine wahl hatten
wir würden sie vielleicht ins gefängnis
schicken aber nur damit sie keinen unfug
mehr veranstaltungen können nicht um sie
zu bestrafen weil es geht nicht um
strafe diese hatten sowieso keine wahl
wenn man daran denkt also wenn man so
schlecht erzogen würde also drogen in
der familie darüber was auch immer man
will eben ist handelt also wenn man
sagen kann also die die kindheit einer
person war so schlimm dass diese person
sozusagen automatisch böse geworden ist
würden wir vielleicht denken okay
deswegen wollen wir diese person nicht
so hart bestrafen oder vielleicht gar
nicht bestrafen sie die person hatte
keine wahl
aber solange werden wir wahrscheinlich
sagen wollen mit den worten ihr mann
waren wenn wir die beta realistische
institutionen haben werden wir
wahrscheinlich mit den worten sagen
wollen
ich muss zwischen den zwei möglichkeiten
die entscheidungen treffen können und
das muss ich sein der entscheidet
hauptargument gegen diese these in der
jetzigen philosophie ist wahrscheinlich
dass es unerklärlich ist warum ich so
entscheide statt so das scheint eine art
magie zu sein
es kann jetzt kann nicht unter den
besatz der gesetze der physik erklärt
werden weil wenn die physik das erklärt
dann bezwingt mich die welt soll so
handeln
also ich muss irgendwie sozusagen
außerhalb der kausalen kette der
physischen welt irgendwie eingreifen
müssen um so steuern statt so und das
scheint es also mehr als ein bisschen
komisch ist ein
manchmal sagen kompatibel ist das
einfach eine art beliebigkeit sein muss
weil wenn ich wirklich sagen muss es
selbst wenn ich alle meine motivationen
und ansichten und die ganze situation
der welt mit betrachte trotzdem sind
verschiedene optionen noch offen
es kann keine erklärung geben warum ich
so gehandelt habe statt so oder würde
mich so gehandhabt stadt nicht so
behandeln das ist nicht die kritik was
die asche riten bringen
die kritik ist vielmehr dass die mutter
suiten mir die fähigkeit fähigkeit geben
was zu schaffen nämlich diese handlung
und nur gott gott geschöpfe also die
mortalität lehre als asymmetrische sicht
ist ein stoß gegen die all mächtigkeit
gottes man kann sogar sagen dass wir
hier eine saison eine spannung zwischen
der gerechtigkeit gottes haben also mit
dem motto bietet die was die mieten
betont haben und die an mächtigkeit
gottes nämlich sein
seine fähigkeit seine alleinige
fähigkeit alles zu schaffen
die einfache version dieser these ist
gott nur gottes schöpfe ich kann nicht
stopfen schaffen deswegen kann ich meine
hand einige handlungen nicht zustande
bringen vielleicht ein komplizierter
erfassung und das genug für die athleten
das die normalerweise normale
analytische these ich glaube wenn man
das ein bisschen stärker machen könnte
könnte man auch darauf deuten dass
selbst wenn ich wirklich in der lage bin
zu schaffen
sicherlich wenn gott allmächtiges könnt
ihr mich stoppen wenn er wollte weil er
alles machen kann also er hätte mich
bezwingen können nicht so so handeln
also um das mindeste zu sagen muss er
irgendwie ermöglichen dass ich handle
stadt nicht zu handeln weil er mich
immer daran verändern könnte
deswegen ist es ja irgendwie immer im
spiel als ursache
aber wie gesagt die engagierten wollten
sogar weiters gehen und sagen dass gott
diese handlung schafft weil nur
erschaffen kann und das klingt auch
leipzigs schlüssig und vielleicht sogar
überzeugend hat aber natürlich ein
problem nämlich dass es jetzt scheint es
genau das daraus folgt was dem aus
eliten gewarnt haben
gott wird unrecht tun nicht vergessen
diese handel mit die wir jetzt
betrachten ist eine sünde ist nichts
geschenkt hier für meine frau kaufen
oder sowas
das ist zum beispiel geld klauen oder
ermorden oder sowas und die mutter
suiten
deswegen sagen ja hier arbeiten dass wir
um die allmächtigen gottes zu schützen
behaupten sie dass gott schlechte taten
begeht
dadurch dass er diese sündhafte handlung
schafft wie können die asche riten
dieses problem umgehen
zweierlei erstens sagen sie ihre
mortalität tun als ob tut als ob die
gerechtigkeit irgendwie eine liste von
regeln ist die gott folgen muss aber das
stimmt nicht
die gerechtigkeit wird so definiert dass
gerechte ist das was gott will
wenn gott es irgendeine irgendeiner
weise handelt zum beispiel weil er die
welt schafft zählt das automatisch als
gerecht weil es per definitionem
unmöglich ist das gott irgendwas
unrechts das gott unrecht tut oder dass
er irgendwas macht was und also nicht
gerecht
zb wurde ihnen die asche riten sagen
wenn gott wollte könnte er alle sünder
in himmel schicken und alle gute
menschen in die halle halle die
gläubigen die rolle und wir können ihnen
dann nicht sagen hey gott was wir jetzt
das was man könnte sagen tut mir leid
aber ich bin gott ich tue was ich will
was wollt ihr jetzt mir sagen was
gerecht ist und was nicht geht es ist
bin doch gott und dann müssen wir sagen
okay also wenn die mieten sagen wenn
wenn gott diese handlung schafft ist er
und merkt würden sie würden die alten
sagen ihr frevler gott kann nicht
unrecht tun natürlich bei der definition
das ist wichtig weil das ist ein frühes
beispiel und vielleicht sogar das
früheste beispiel in der geschichte der
philosophie so weit wie ich weiß aber es
gibt das soll man nie sagen es gibt
immer handelt es gibt immer andere
beispiele die früher sind aber an das
sogenannte weinkamm das ist eine gängige
theorie in der ethik und das also diese
theorie setzt voraus dass die ethik
kommt davon dass es gott gibt und dass
gott irgendwelche regeln aufstellt zum
beispiel ist mord ungerecht weil gott
mord verboten hat das sehen wir sehr
klar in denen wir touristen im 14
jahrhundert in der lateinischen welt
aber die akten sind 400 jahre schneller
weil die commercials adicom tim seiten
jahrhundert
und die arbeiten würden sagen mit der
divine würden sie sagen ja das gerecht
ist nur das was gott weil kein problem
vielleicht kennen manche von ihnen ein
dialog von traktor platten der frauen
heißt wenn da jetzt da wir das gefragt
ist das da es nicht gerechtigkeit
sondern frömmigkeit ist das ist
frömmigkeit from weil gott
das haben will oder will gottes haben
weil es zum beispiel ist es von an die
götter zu opfern weil gott opfer haben
will oder will gott opfer haben weil es
from es an gott zu opfern
also in welche richtung geht die
kausalität susan und die asche riten
sagen ich sehr klar frömmigkeit
gerechtigkeit einfach gut das gute im
allgemeinen ist gut weil gott es haben
will nicht umgekehrt
es gibt keinen spielregeln für gott also
das sehr interessant dass die
architekten das vertreten haben trotzdem
es sind sie unter druck irgendwie zu
erklären warum wir moralisch
verantwortlich sind und nicht so sehr
weil es unbemerkt werde wenn gott uns
bestrafen würde ohne uns andere
möglichkeiten zu geben sondern weil es
in dem koran steht dass gott verspricht
die guten in die wüste schicken und die
schlachten in die hölle
also ist es klar dass gott gegen wie die
welt so geschaffen hat dass es
moralische verantwortung gibt und die
athleten wollen genauso wie die
mordabsichten wollen sie erklären warum
es ist dass ich für diese handlung
verantwortlich bin und ihre erklärung
ist folgendes ich kann nichts schaffen
nur gott kann schaffen deswegen schafft
gott die handlung aber wenn die handlung
geschaffen wird wird sie von mir
erworben
also das arabische wort hier ist also
erwerb ist dies also zum beispiel wie
ich ein wie ich ein auto erwerben kann
also jemand macht das auto und ich
erwerbe das auto dadurch dass ich das
auto kaufe was heißt das schwer zu sagen
aber wahrscheinlich ist die idee dass
gott die handlung schafft aber die
handlung irgendjemanden gibt oder
jemanden bestimmt eine bestimmte person
in verbindung mit dieser handlung setzt
weil sie zum beispiel wenn ich geld
klauen ist nichts als ob sie das geld
geklaut haben also dass die handlung
gehört mehr irgendwie selbst mein gott
die handlung geschaffen hat und deswegen
frage ich für die handlung verantwortung
weil ich das weil ich sie übernommen hat
susan von gott die mortalität
pensionierten nicht überraschenderweise
haben gesagt ja was soll das sein
wenn gott sie sich entscheidet mir eine
sündhaft handlungs zu geben und ich
erwerbe sie dann habe ich keine wahl und
die asche riten sagen doch er schafft
für mich die handlungen die ich beginne
also wenn ich mich entscheide soll so
handeln
das ist geld zu klauen zum beispiel
schafft gott die handlung clown in mir
und dann erwerbe ich diese handlung
alles ohne dass ich eine andere
möglichkeit hatte warum hat man hier
keine andere möglichkeit weil es nicht
es nicht als ob ich
gott bezwingen kann diese handlung so
geht mir diese handlung zu gehen statt
nicht zu geben dann wäre er nicht
allmächtig wieder gott weiß was ich
machen wird und schafft einfach die
handlungen die ich irgendwie machen muss
und es gibt keine susanne unbenutzte
fähigkeit nicht zu handeln
wir haben nur die fähigkeit zu handeln
die dieses leid war sehr lang und sehr
kompliziert und einen teil der streit
zwischen den zwei gruppen von rotter
calyon war eben diese frage der
fähigkeit also die katholiken sagten
dass die person eine fähigkeit besitzt
entweder so handeln oder nichts und die
asche riten sagen nein du hast nur die
die fähigkeit zu handeln und gott
schafft die fähigkeit sowohl wie die
handlung
er schafft alles es gibt gar nichts was
er nicht schafft also heikel servicemann
wenn sie sagen ja du wolltest stellen
und deswegen hat gott die behandlung
geschaffen
selbst das wollen muss auch von gott
geschaffen werden
also es gibt sozusagen nie einen moment
wo der die person irgendwas macht ohne
dass gott die mit physischen ursache
dafür ist sie haben auch ein argumente
warum es nicht so sein kann dass wir die
fähigkeit haben die handlung zu begehen
oder nichts nämlich wenn ich diese hat
diese ist so eins weiß seite die
handball fähigkeit habe entweder so
handle oder nicht muss ich auch die
fähigkeit haben zu entscheiden welche
seite der fähigkeit eingesetzt wird
also ich muss sagen die fähigkeit haben
so handeln oder nicht und dann eine
weitere fähigkeit haben zu entscheiden
aber dann müsste ich natürlich die
entscheiden die fähigkeit haben entweder
zu entscheiden oder nichts und dann muss
ich eine weitere fähigkeit haben
entweder diese fähigkeit zum 1 1
und so weiter und so fort und wir werden
sehen dass es einen weg gibt bis ins
unendliche von fähigkeiten das ist
unschlüssig es kann nicht sein
deswegen gibt es keine unbenutzte
fähigkeiten das ist ein klares argument
ok also ich will nicht unbedingt sagen
der verdacht hat interessante ist
vielleicht zu sehen
wie also erstens möchte ich betonen dass
ist offensichtlich philosophie sie
zitieren zwar gegeneinander koranische
wersen usw aber das ist in meinen wenn
das nicht eine philosophische kontrovers
ist dann bin ich kein philosoph also ich
würde es ist für mich ein paradebeispiel
von meiner these die ich jetzt sehr oft
bedroht habe
das kann ein teil der geschichte der
philosophie ist und anerkannt werden
soll also ersten und zweiten es gibt ja
wenn man sich fragt wo ist wo ist die
interessante auseinandersetzung wegen
freiheit und determinismus in der
islamischen welt die antwort ist
eigentlich hin kann und nicht jedenfalls
dass die fifa sagen normalerweise ja wir
haben halle die fähigkeit zu entscheiden
untätig ist dann die veranstalter flüsse
wo man das erforscht und das war es aber
eine für eine tiefgehende diskussion der
freiheit und was freiheit eigentlich ist
was die verlauf satz muss man kann am
lesen nicht weißer okay
ja gute frage wir kommen eigentlich dazu
war ich dann später über determinismus
als folge des wissen gottes sprechen
werde aber immer interessante für die
mordserie team werde ob gott schon im
voraus weiß was ich machen werde
die athleten können natürlich sagen ja
weil er weiß was er schaffen wird die
machteliten sie müssen entweder sagen
dass gott wartet um es zu sehen was ich
machen werde dass gott im voraus schon
bewusst ist
die handeln werde aber keinen einfluss
darauf hat und das ist genau die
philosophische frage die ich dann in den
letzten 20 minuten bestreiten werde
andere fragen zu callen das wird dann
weitergehe
[Musik]
also kam im allgemeinen hat fast keinen
einfluss auf europäisches denken selbst
razali der ein kalender ist seine
carlisle cullen werke würden nicht ins
in die lateinische sprache übersetzt und
im allgemeinen okay obwohl das sind es
nur noch mal zurück zu der frage warum
nehmen wir das nicht als belastet war
ein grund dafür ist dass die arabische
welt ins lateinische übersetzt wurden
waren fast ausschließlich aus falls aber
nicht aus kahl am main erfasst haben sie
recht ist nun keine historische
verbindung es gibt eine parallele
entwicklung in der lateinischen im bett
wo wollen tourismus wie gesagt anfang
des 14 jahrhundert ja sehr stark
geworden ist hier ist der schlüssel
denke es dann scorers und aus mit
deutliche wollen tourismus haben wir
dann diese intuitionen die für uns so
stattfinden die auch unser rechtssystem
prägen also mit der öffentliche
philosophie ist relevant und eine
entwicklung die parallel ist der kanal
entwicklung ist auch sehr wichtig aber
ich würde nicht sagen dass es eine
historische wende gibt zb weißer im 1
vielleicht kann man so etwas nie
ausschließen nicht dass ich wüsste ja
verständnis
das scheint mir
also ja gut das ist dann ja ich wollte
dass das erklären
das habe ich vergessen darf also ich
würde das als kompatibel ist ish
beschreiben weil ich bei diese
möglichkeit nicht vorhanden ist und die
würden trotzdem sagen wir haben das
gewählt wir haben gehandelt wird das war
unsere wahl also die wurden all diese
zusagen entscheidung des wörther
hernehmen um das zu beschreiben wie
gesagt sie sagen die handlung wird für
mich geschaffen wenn ich sie will und
deswegen sind sie für mich nahezu
kompatibel ist muss und sich sagen
nichts sie würden nichts sagen aber es
sind sowieso nicht moralisch
verantwortlich weil es sowieso keine
wahl hatten wie die heutige trends die
die sind immerhin die bestehen wirklich
darauf dass die freiheit hier gesichert
haben
aber freiheit heißt die freiheit soll so
handeln wie gott verschafft weil ich so
handeln wollte und sie ein anderes
beispiel dafür und das ist auch sehr
klassisch kompatibel ist
sie unterscheiden zum beispiel zwischen
normale handlung und zittern
von krankheit und geben also geben diese
beispiele um zu sagen wenn ich nur
zittere von krankheit das ist nichts
eine handlung die die ich wählen wollte
die gott für mich schafft ist nur eine
akzidenz was für mich geschaffen wird
weil ich krank bin also die
unterscheiden zwischen gewollte oder
gewählte handlungen und nichts gewählte
handlung handlungen vor der taten wie
zittern zum beispiel gott interessanter
weise wie wir bei es alle gesehen haben
vielleicht erkennen sie sich daran dass
ich gesagt habe dass gott für rosalie
zwischen gleichgültige im moment
entscheiden kann für der hahn für den
anfang der welt ja also wenn es um
gottes willen
um gottes willen wenn es um die wille
gottes geht plötzlich werden die arten
der liebe tennis tisch also führt gott
weil sie dieses problem mit einem
mächtigkeit jetzt nicht mehr habe er ist
der mächtige wenn er welt sind sie ganz
damit zufrieden dass er zwischen
möglichkeiten werden das ist genau was
sie wollen
das ist nur dass wir das nicht machen
können weil wir da gegen seine alm
mächtigkeit stoßen würden wenn wir ja
immer schaffen würden aber wie gesagt
selbst wenn nur eine handlung in der
geschichte der welt frei ist und
moralische verantwortung trägt ohne dass
man eine andere wahl hatte ist man
kompatibel ist ich deswegen obwohl ist
die lippetal realistisch die wille
gottes beschreiben sind sie meiner
meinung nach ein paar zivilisten
okay okay
[Musik]
und hatte ich diesen straßen jetzt
hatten wir gerne ausgehen oder haben
[Musik]
es ist ein handeln was in diese
überlegung nicht
ja das hat mir sehr aufgeschlossen also
die die frage ich hier ist wenn denn ich
habe was ist die handlung und ob das in
meiner macht liegt oder nicht zum
beispiel nehmen wir an sie wollen mich
erschießen nur eine andere
sie wollen mich erschießen dass sie
nehmen ihre pistole bei aber nichts
passiert war die pistole mit
funktioniert das ist willkür und sie
haben glück weil sie dass man nur in
mordversuche nicht mord und deswegen
könnte man vielleicht sagen dass selbst
wenn sie mich erfolgreich umbringen
würden werde mein tod nicht ihre
handlung jede handlung ist vielleicht
die körperliche bewegung oder vielleicht
sogar die bewegung in der seele
die die körperliche bewegung verursacht
und all diese fragen würden in calama
auch diskutiert es gibt einen ort singen
von der montage liter so lieb und haben
das kommt von dem wort erzeugen
also was ist zb kennt und das heißt aldi
volg die unmittelbare folgen
unmittelbare folgen meiner taten sind
auch meine taten zb wenn ich irgendwas
stossend dass zum beispiel wenn wenn ich
sie aus dem fenster werfen und sie
fallen auf einen anderen menschen
überleben aber er ist tot
ich habe ihnen auch umgebracht obwohl es
sie ihn
ich habe ihn nicht berührt wir haben
neue sie berührt auch nur eine annahme
dass können wir ausprobieren am ende der
vorlesung
wir müssen warten bis jemand runter geht
das ist ein fall von cavallo und das
heißt eine unmittelbare folge oder
vermittelte folge meine handlung neu
sind nicht ganz klar was meine handlung
dann wirklich es aber ist irgendwie das
erste was passiert worüber ich date habe
nach dem motto das lied aber sie haben
recht das kann also irgend es kommt sehr
sehr viel da es kommt immer darauf an
wie die welt reagiert so sagen ob meine
handlungen erfolgreich sind aber das ist
nicht der punkt der punkt ist ich
entscheide vielleicht zu einem versuch
zu machen so handeln oder nicht jetzt
dann wollte ich was zu determinismus
sagen und zuerst erkennen dass es
eigentlich zwei arten von determinismus
gibt's in der philosophie was ich
logischer und kausalität termin ismus
benennen würde kausale determinismus ist
wahrscheinlich das was zuerst einfällt
wenn ich determinismus sage und das habe
ich immer wieder gesagt wir haben
naturgesetze die situation der welt und
vielleicht also wenn die welt
deterministisch ist könnten wir sagen
wenn wir zum beispiel die jetzige lage
des universums nehmen und dann die
naturgesetze betrachten muss alles
automatisch daraus folgen in die zukunft
und das würde bedeuten dass alles was in
der zukunft vorkommen wird notwendig ist
unvermeidbar weil es natürlich mit in
unserer macht ist die jetzige
gesamtsituation der welt zu beeinflussen
weder es ist möglich die naturgesetze zu
ändern
als alle tennis muss man kann das
vielleicht so beschreiben dass wir ein
ereignis haben und dieses ereignis gilt
von einer anderen ereignis geschah sagt
ein frühes ereignis und so weiter
und wenn wir vielleicht zurück zum
anfang der welt gehen oder auch eine
beliebige zeit in der vergangenheit ist
es der fall dass diese ereignisse die
hier stattfinden die jetzige ereignisse
garantieren und vermeintlich deutlich
machen
okay die kausalkette so sagen vielleicht
gibt es sehr viele casale captain aber
der punkt ist dass jede kette unser
praktisch ist und jeder glied jeder
kette garantiert also notwendig macht
die den nächsten schritt oder glied der
kette
wie gesagt dass es so was man
normalerweise denkt wenn man an
determinismus denkt es gibt aber auch
logische determinismus logischer
determinismus hat gar nichts mit
physische oder sogar andere ursachen
oder causa alle beziehungen zu tun hat
stattdessen mit wahrheit zu tun also
grob ist die idee gestern war es schon
war dass ich heute die vorlesung halten
würde
deswegen war es schon gestern irgendwie
entschieden dass ich jetzt vorlese
deswegen vor der sich jetzt notwendig
wir kommen jetzt kam später dazu zurück
aber zuerst möchte ich was über casale
determinismus sagen
ok erstens kommt dieses bild und
vielleicht sehr krank vor wie eine
horizontale fassung der neue platte
blood neue platonischen emulation werde
die von fabi und harvey seiner
übernommen würde also zur eröffnung im
neuen platzes muss haben wird es eine
und das eine emin irrt wie ein licht
eine quelle news oder internet daraus
hat seele claassen herr fuchs natur oder
die fahrt der denkt der kosmos ähnlicher
weise bei ferrari in arizona gibt es
gott gott terminiert ein erstes internet
dann haben wir eine reihe von intellekt
[Musik]
die intellekt und intellekt es sind
jeweils mit himmels verbunden wie wir
gesehen haben
und das laste intellekt terminiert die
formen der natur
[Musik]
ich werde vielleicht später mehr dazu
sagen aber der punkt ist alles stroms
aus gott hier runter und natürlich sind
all diese ursachen unwiderstehlich
nein so war für gott haben und nicht
vergessen nach es eines nachweises eines
gottes lehre ist gott nicht nur
notwendig existenz sondern alles was mit
gott zu tun hat ist notwendig also seien
chinas schöpfen seine emulation der welt
und diese intellekts kette ist alles
notwendig und nichts kann das wieder
stellen also das fließt runter saison
diese möglichkeit fliesst runter hier
und jetzt und impliziert sogar dass ich
zum beispiel jetzt vorlese ist es
interessant weil wenn wir haben hier
einen art kausalen determinismus aber
nicht wie wir das normalerweise
verstehen wo das wirklich mit ereignisse
in der vergangenheit zu tun hat die die
jetzige ereignisse verursachen
der punkt ist vielmehr dass die dass der
casale einfluss gottes so stark ist so
notwendig ist das alles nur eine folge
dieser notwendigkeit ist also eine frage
ist dann ob fabio oder aber das wirklich
akzeptieren und ein indiz dafür dass es
einer wirklich deterministisch denkt ist
eben das was er über das kontingent er
sagt vielleicht erinnern sie sich daran
haben das ist was wir gesehen haben als
wir sein gottesbeweis diskutiert haben
ein kontingentes wie sich vielleicht
daran erinnern ist das was entweder
existieren kann oder nicht
ja zum beispiel ich bin per se ja so aus
meiner natur aus nicht garantiert zu
existieren
ich kann entweder existieren oder nicht
und wenn man sich fragt warum existiere
ich stadt nicht zu akzeptieren
existieren sagt er
der grund ist eine ursache es gibt immer
eine ursache die notwendig macht das das
kontinente existiert wenn es existiert
und nichts existiert wenn es nicht
existiert und diese ursache wenn sie
auch kontingent war war genauso
verursacht zu existieren also diese
kette hier diese vertikale kette oder
auch eine horizontale kette nach hd
senders analyse ist immer so dass jeder
schritt ihre glieder in der kette würde
kam überwiegt zu existieren scheint
nicht zu existieren und was wirklich
sehr auffällig ist das ist das erbe
seiner den unterschied zwischen gott und
geschaffene dinge erklärt sagt er
gott ist also notwendig existierende
aber es ist notwendig eines in sich
selbst oder durch sie selbst
ripplewood wie dati oder bis sie das
geschaffene ding also alle andere dinge
sind in sich selbst kontingents aber
notwendig durch ein anderer
nun kennen die nun pilati
aber das heißt notwendig durch eine
ursache doch sonst irgendwas und wenn
man das betrachtet scheint es sehr
heiligen zu sein dass für hd sender
alles obwohl an sich kontingent durch
diese kotthaus alle kette notwendig wird
also er ist anscheinend ein klassischer
der termin ist
wir sehen wie diese annahmen dann zu
vorkommen können in der geschichte der
astrologie in der islamischen welt die
sehr oft mit philosophie verbunden ist
weil viele für das surfen an die die
waren auch vertreter der astrologischen
wissenschaft und oft sagen sie das an
diese diese himmels fällen die mit dem
internet verbunden sind die ereignisse
hier unten verursachen und dass wir sie
im voraus vorhersehen können weil wenn
also als astrologen können wir die
himmels bewegungen beobachten und schon
im voraus sehen was passieren wird zb
dass es krieg gegen wird dass jemand
eine erfolgreiches leben haben wird oder
wir oder
ich wollte was über archäologie in der
jüdischen flow situation sagen
die zeit wäre ein bisschen hängen also
kurzum was ich sagen wollte ist dass
ökologie in jüdischer flossen
analysieren im mittelalter sehr sehr
umstritten war aber auch unter
muslimischen denken umstritten aber die
jüdische 24 wirklich auffällig wie
wichtig das war zum beispiel gibt es
einen katalog für das dorf namens
abraham hin esra der anscheinend ein
astra der termin ist war also er ist
praktisch apathisch diese art vertikale
deterministische theorie wo die
himmlisch wo die sterne planeten und
sterne alle ereignisse auf erde dann
verursachen
andere anhänger der archäologie zb im
dauert haben dann haben gesagt ja
richtig bis auf menschlicher menschliche
handlung dass es irgendwie eine ausnahme
und dann hat er es eine politische
erklärung von menschlicher handlung und
sagt normalerweise werden alle
ereignisse runden von den sternen
gesteuert und kontrolliert aber wenn ich
handle dann nichts
vielleicht weil ich eine körperliche
seele habe und das ist irgendwie immun
gegen hast du aus zahl astral einfluss
bei mona dies schreibt dann einen brief
über astrologie wo er sagt das ist das
schlimmste was man sagen kann also er
ist super super gegen also logi und
beschuldigt sogar die astrologen einen
antiken juden kommen
dass der tempel zerstört würde es war er
sagt wenn sie sich für krieg ausgerüstet
hätten statt die ganze zeit an
astrologie zu vertrauen
würde der tempel loch stehen sein
vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben von
ihm aber er ist wirklich ein fan ein
sehr überzeugter gegner der astrologie
also seien interessante
auseinandersetzung hinter jüdischen
flüsse wie ok aber haben für die
restliche zeit wollte ich über den
anderen art termin ist die anderen
termin ismus starten und das ist logisch
zu krimis muss wie gesagt ist das
problem hier hat das problem hier nichts
mit ursachen zu tun das ist hat nichts
mit kausale beziehungen zu tun es hat
mit wahrheit zu tun deswegen heißt es
logischer determinismus und das berühmte
argument dafür wird zum ersten mal bei
der schotte ließ erwähnt im neuen
kapitel von der interpretation und das
argument lautet folgendes nehmen wir an
dass es morgen eine seeschlacht geben
wird
ok nennen wir haben dieses diesen satz
okay wenn er es wahr ist wenn es morgen
einen schlag geben wird ist schon jetzt
der fall dass die seeschlacht
stattfinden wird
offensichtlich ist es jetzt irgendwie
egal was die regierung entscheidet ob
die matrosen anderes denken also so
irgendwie muss es dazu kommen dass es
eine seeschlacht geben wird selbst wenn
alle menschen das nicht haben wollen
also irgendwie das fatalistisch wird das
vorkommen weil sonst wäre es nicht schon
war also wenn es jetzt sofort ist nicht
also ob wir sagen wenn ja diese dieser
satz ist jetzt war es war aber trotzdem
findet dies lag nicht statt
natürlich muss die stadt wenden ja und
natürlich gilt das für alle ereignisse
dazu kommt wenn es jetzt wahrheiten über
diese ereignisse gibt dann ist es schon
entschieden dass sie vorkommen werden
oder nicht
zum beispiel der satz nicht erst nämlich
einen schlag wird morgen nicht
stattfinden
dieser satz ist nach unserer annahme
dieser satzes falsch war falsch kranken
können nicht umgetauscht werden
also es ist schon entschieden dass diese
schlagzeilen wird und dass sie nicht
stattfinden wird deswegen ist dieser
zeit schon war die dosis falsch und das
gilt für alle zukünftige ereignisse
deswegen sind alle zukünftige ereignisse
notwendig das ist das berühmte
seeschlacht argument ist klar wie sehr
das problem wie sollen wir das problem
lösen
ok fangen wir mit atoss lösung
dieses lösung keine ahnung weil herr
gibt eine lösung aber es ist sehr
umstritten was er sagen wird
es gibt es die sogenannte traditionelle
interpretation und diese interaktion ist
ganz simpel
nach der traditionellen interpretation
will assad ließ sagen dass er das obwohl
und das ist sehr gut
worum her dass in einem logischen werk
vorstellt das problem
er spricht über die frage unter welchen
bedingungen setzte war sind und nichts
und im allgemeinen will er sagen dass
jeder satz der eine eine bedeutung hat
also jeder katholische bedeutungsvolle
satz ist entweder wahr oder falsch
und dann sagt dann würde eine ausnahme
machen zu sagen okay bis auf in dem fall
wo der satz über die zukunft geht über
ein kontingentes ereignis weil dann wenn
wir dann sagen dass dieser satz war erst
ist die seeschlacht ein notwendiges
ereignis und das wollen wir natürlich
nicht
das ist die internationale
interpretation er würde einfach
verneinen dass das jetzige wahrheiten
über zukünftige kontingente ereignisse
gibt die nicht rationelle interpretation
werde dass er irgendwie sagen will
ja dieser satz sph aber nur kontingente
war oder nur notwendig notwendig war und
deswegen obwohl dies stattfinden wird
wird sie nicht notwendig stattfinden
sie seien ein bisschen unklar vielleicht
aber zum glück wird es bei al arabi sehr
klar
glasklar wir haben einen aufsatz darüber
geschrieben was auf dem herrnhaag ist
also bin ich nicht der aufsatz titel des
absatzes
ok ferrari hat einen kommentar zu diesem
berg von art der interpretation und
kommentiert diese stelle und er sagt
okay das problem ist eben das jetzige
wahrheit notwendige ereignisse in der
zukunft impliziert deswegen können wir
sagen dass die jetzige wahrheit nicht
determiniert ist das in der terminiert
und das ist schon ein ausdruck was man
in spätantike griechische kommentare zu
der gleichen stelle bei der sache ließ
vorkommt die frage ist dann was das
heißt in determiniert und wahrscheinlich
was wahrscheinlich was die spätantike
kommentatoren damit meint sagen wollten
und ich glaube sicherlich was ferrari
damit sagen will ist sowas wie folgendes
hat ließ wollte das so genannte prinzip
von bayerns festhalten also prinzip bei
wärmen sich lieber wäre uns auf deutsch
heißt hätte ich nach schlagen sollen
aber das hat aber das prinzip ist
folgendes zwei wertigkeit haben sie das
gerade erfunden
könnt ihr wissen im prinzip der zwei
wertigkeit ist der satz ist dieser satz
also jeder satz der einst den einzeln
ergibt und der was fast jede behauptung
sind wieder wahr oder falsch 1 oder den
oder das andere
nichts weder noch nicht weder falsch
noch war und wie gesagt die deputation
macht dann eine ausnahme für solche sich
über die zukunft und ferrari sagt diese
sind in die terminiert und das heißt es
und nicht erst sind also sind jeweils
eines davon einfach es war der andere
falsch aber ist noch nicht entschieden
welche es welche also die wahrheit
schwebt sozusagen und wartet zu sehen wo
sie landen sollen
und wenn diese vielleicht endlich
vorkommt landet sie auf es dann wird es
war so sagen ich finde dass es keine
gute lösung
übrigens der philosophisch gesehen
findet ferrari auch die wir gleich sehen
werden aber aus einem anderen grund der
grünen wofür ich das keine gute lösung
finden ist einfach das folgende nehmen
wir an sie sagen zu mir eine seeschlacht
wird morgen stattfinden
und ich sage nein stimmt doch nicht
morgen seeschlacht da sterben tausende
aber was mich stört ist dass ich nicht
recht hatte weil ich so rein und ich
gehe zu ihnen und sage ach ich bin so
frustriert sie hatten recht und ich
nichts
es wäre meiner meinung nach irgendwie
nicht überzeugen wenn sie sagen wenn
keine sorge als wir dieses streit hatten
war die wahrheit noch nicht terminiert
also weder ich noch
hat es hatten rechts weil die wahrheit
waren noch nichts entschieden
nein es ist sehr für mich ist sehr
intuitiv zu sagen dass einer von uns
schon heute recht hat und der andere
nicht
aber nach dieser interpretation oder die
verwirrung ist das nicht der fall
wir können sogar sagen zum beispiel wenn
ich jetzt sage bayern wird die therme
sieger gewinnen
vielleicht also normalerweise wenn ich
so etwas sage
würden sie sagen dass plausibel neuer
trainer
wenn man das nicht verletzt wird
aber nein nach dieser lösung müssen sie
sagen hey das was sie sagen ist
definitiv nicht wahr
nicht wahr weil das eine zukunft ein
zukünftiges ereignis ist es gibt keine
wahrheit
wieso kommt der gehört eigentlich finde
das einfach unglaublich gut dann das
ferrari 1 auch eine zweite lösung
vorschlägt unterstellte aus einem
anderen grund vor nämlich dass er die
befürchtung hat das wird nach dieser
lösung des vorwissen gottes nicht
schützen können
also herr saxe ausdrücklich nach dieser
interpretation oder diese lösung wäre es
nicht der fall dass gott schon jetzt
weiß ob es eine schlacht geben wird oder
nicht weil es noch nicht entschieden ist
welcher satz war ist es oder nicht erst
und wenn es noch nichts zu sagen in der
welt entschieden ist ob es eine selbst
geben wird oder nicht kann gottes
natürlich nicht wissen es gibt keine
wahrheit die er wissen kann
deswegen sagt ralf arabi und jetzt kommt
eine version der zweiten lösung aber
sehr klar formuliert er ist sagt nehmen
wir jetzt erst
von es von der wahrheit von es folgt die
seeschlacht würde das stattfinden der
seeschlacht und diese folge hier ist
eine notwendige folge genau wie es zum
beispiel aus
[Applaus]
das ist eine notwendige folge
das ist normal dass polens wenn dann qpr
deswegen kuh und ko erfolg notwendig aus
diesem aus diesem diesen prämissen ja
aber das heißt ball am langen nicht das
notwendig war ist weil diese zwei
prämisse dan caten kuh dann crew und pay
vielleicht nur kontingent war sind wir
anders gesagt die modalität
notwendigkeit möglichkeit von vom
schluss ist nur so stark wie das
schwächste prämisse obwohl die
beziehungen zwischen den prämissen und
die folge wurde das schloss dem schluss
eine notwendige beziehung ist genauso in
diesem fall
es ist natürlich 100 eine notwendige
folge aus der wahrheit von erst das 1
stattfinden muss aber das heißt nur dass
die sales schlag notwendig stattfinden
muss wenn es eine notwendige wahrheit
ist aber das ist keine notwendige war
hat das nur eine kontingente wahrheit
worauf ist sie kontingents auf das
stattfinden der schlacht und deswegen
ist es einfach ein fehler war immer
einen fehler zu denken das jetzige
wahrheit zukünftige notwendigkeit
impliziert meiner meinung nach ist das
die richtige lösung
das selbst problems
und ich denke auch dass ferrari
wahrscheinlich der erste philosoph der
das klar formuliert das kommt dann
später im 14 jahrhundert wir im
lateinischen in der lateinischen welt
vor
aber so weit wie ich weiß noch mal ist
immer schwierig zu sagen er jemand ist
der erste ist irgendwas sozusagen aber
ist so weit wie ich weiß dass ferrari
der erste der wirklich klar diese lösung
zu lösung von wird manche denken dass
die spätantike kommentatoren als sie
dieses diese dieser diesen vorschlag in
determinierte wahrheit gemacht haben
vielleicht haben sie damit nicht gemeint
wahrheit die noch nichts gelandet ist
sondern kontingente wahrheit aber das
ist zuerst zu sagen dass auch um städten
das gute bei ferrari ist das ja wirklich
super ausdrücklich sagt dass dies
notwendig daraus folgen kann ohne
notwendig zu sein also etwas alpharadin
er ist der gewinner von heute außer dass
jemand eine sehr gute frage hat baden
kommentare